who pays the bill for the shutdown is
shaping up to be the next big political
battle state and local leaders make the
shutdown decision but they want Congress
to pay the cost for things like
massively higher unemployment insurance
that's blown a hole in their finances
Pelosi and Schumer say this is their
redline for the next big relief bill the
fifth one by the way Mitch McConnell is
not having any of it neither treasurer
et cetera Steve minuchin who rejected it
tonight Mitch McConnell called the idea
a blue state bailout he suggested that
instead states should be able to declare
bankruptcy which Republican Larry Hogan
head of the National Governors
Association called complete nonsense and
Andrew Cuomo not wanting to be outdone
described as one of the dumbest ideas of
all time so what is really going on here
most importantly should President Trump
back more money for state and local
government because in the end is his
position that's going to be crucial
inadvertently it was actually Governor
Cuomo who put his finger on it
bailout us them now it's just theater
it's just smoke and mirrors to avoid the
American people seeing the reality which
is whose pocket they want to put money
in versus whose pocket state and local
governments want to fund exactly
governor whose pocket do state and local
governments want to fund all too often
especially in blue states
it's the pockets of the public sector
unions who fund and organize their
political campaigns let's try and make
this as clear as we can one it's
reasonable for the federal government to
help pay for emergency coronavirus costs
but not to plug budget holes that were
there before the pandemic the National
Governors Association wants unrestricted
funds that is not okay to chapter 9
bankruptcy is a tool that some cities
have used to keep services going Mitch
McConnell's suggestion far from hurting
local service providers would actually
help them
it would hurt banks and other creditors
it's the opposite of what Larry Hogan
and the Democrats said three Democrats
are trying to claim that it's actually
blue states that bailout red states
because they put more money
into federal coffers than they take out
while many red states are net recipients
but that's not a bailout
that's called redistribution I thought
Democrats were in favor of it a bailout
means rescuing you from the consequences
of your past choices like piling up debt
by giving public sector unions luxury
pensions and other retirement benefits
that private sector workers could only
dream of those costs in states like
California Illinois and New York have
been blowing a hole in state's budgets
for years in February before coronavirus
hit Illinois governor Pritzker's budget
of just over 40 billion had nine billion
just for pensions nearly a quarter
giving States unrestricted money now
would give them yet another excuse to
put off the reforms that are vital so
yes help the states pay for shutdown
costs but not if they prolong the
shutdown and only if they first cut the
unfair spending that only benefits their
donors the public sector unions this is
just like the state and local tax
deduction which President Trump rightly
killed off in his great tax cut and
reformed as one leading senator put it
it's irresponsible and reckless to take
money from America's taxpayers and use
it to save liberal politicians from the
consequences of their poor choices that
was Florida senator Rick Scott writing
in The Wall Street Journal this week
senator Scott joins us live next
welcome back everyone Florida Governor
Rick not governor senator Rick Scott
joins me now senator I'm so sorry I
think of you as a governor and by the
way so as I'm concerned that is a
compliment just what you to be clear
about that in fact as a former governor
before we get into this question of the
blue state bailouts just give us an
update on what's going on in your state
we had some very upbeat comments from
governor santa-santa is your success
your success of how do you see things
right now in Florida well I didn't tell
you people are anxious to get back to
work I mean this weekend the state's
been busy you know I live in I live in
Naples Florida and everybody's outside
people people are anxious to get back to
work so Monday it's going to be exciting
to see these restaurants reopen and
these businesses reopen
so I think it's gonna be fine now the
bottom line is I put out a plan it
depends on is your family figure out how
to stay safe Dora businesses or they
really figure out how to make their
customers and their employees safe and
we still have a lot of work to do with
regard to testing that will be done at
every local at every level of government
yeah well just what just one data point
I would highlight from certainly the
presentation I saw from Governor
DeSantis it was predicted by the experts
that there would be four hundred and
sixty five thousand hospitalizations in
the state of Florida they then
excoriated him for being too casual
about all this the actual number of
hospitalizations turned out to be 2111
as of whenever that presentation was
made by the current governor so senator
Scott let's just talk about this
question of money which has been asked
for in the next relief bill for States
do you agree with the characterization
of this as a blue state bailout and what
would your advice be to President Trump
for how to handle this issue in the
weeks ahead you know we look at just
like we've done with hurricanes I had
four major hurricanes as the governor
and basically what they did is they said
we're gonna help you you know deal with
your your cost of you know to clean up
things like that well what we've done in
Congress with our states is weird
beating them with the cost of quarter
virus nobody I mean nobody comes back
and says oh I'm gonna take care of all
your revenue shortfall in my you might
hurricanes I never once saw Governor
Cuomo from New York so you know what we
need to help the governor Scott down
there with this with his revenue
shortfall never once did he say that so
this is just this is just a bailout of
poorly managed states Governor Cuomo and
I got elected the exact same time he
can't balance his budget he just keeps
borrowing money in contrast I walked
with a budget deficit we've over three I
think four billion dollars we balanced
it we paid off a third estate debt so
why should a Florida taxpayer be bailing
out the budget of Governor Cuomo or
other governors of these blue states a
just more detailed point I want to end
with but you'll know this better than
anyone
if money is sent to a state earmarked by
Congress for one purpose you can only
use this for emergency relief can't they
then take that money and use it for some
other purpose is it is it possible to
control it properly well if you if you
look away supposed to work is
historically you'd got reimbursed like
with the hurricane we had to show our
cost then we got reimbursed what they've
done with this they've sent it first but
it still is gonna work the same way if
you didn't have the cost you will owe
that money back so I am all in for
helping states with the cost of the
corona virus just like we did with the
hurricane but I'm not gonna bail out
their bad budget decisions that's the
wrong thing to do and and you'll be
fighting alongside sure
Mitch McConnell on that point how do you
see it playing out politically when this
fight comes to the Senate I look I think
the American public can bully Greece
with us
I mean think about people left it places
like Illinois and New York to come to
Florida because they are tired sick and
tired of those governors in these blue
states not balancing their budgets and
they said why would we come to Florida
and have to bail out Andrew Cuomo or any
other blue state governor so it's not
right there you go very strongly put
appreciate you being with us tonight
governor sorry they I did it again I
just love governors and therefore I
could always use that what I think a
blockage
for your perspective and I really
recommend your article in The Wall
Street Journal it was really really
great thank you for being with us all
the best